it's two weeks ago since you were last
in the studio sitting
in that very chair um i asked you if
there was going to be
another national lockdown and i just
want to play viewers your response to
that question
two to three weeks circuit breaker to
give us some breathing space to get on
top of test and trace
people want to know is that gonna happen
no
it was a one-way answer no why should
people trust
what you're going to tell them today
well during the course of the whole of
that interview i outlined that
we would be willing to take whatever
steps were necessary but it wasn't
necessary
at that point at that point the advice
that we were receiving
was that a regional approach could
succeed in reducing the spread of
infection from
those areas where the infection rate was
high
to those areas where the infection rate
was still relatively speaking
lower but unfortunately over the course
of the last two weeks
the virus has been spreading faster than
predicted and in a way that requires
as you quite rightly pointed out what
the prime minister has described as
uh the nuclear option and
we've taken these steps because we
believe that it's absolutely vitally
necessary
to safeguard the nhs at a time when
the infection rate is doubling when the
number of people going to hospital
is increasing significantly and when the
strain on our health service is such
that we do need to take action it's a
question of trust though isn't it um
because as you say later on in the
interview expand on the answer but when
i ask you directly a simple question
is there going to be a second national
lockdown you chose to give a one-word
answer no there was no nuance on that
well you were asking of course about the
context at that time was there going to
be a circuit breaker
of the kind that was two weeks ago at
that time well one of the things about
the virus is that uh
over the course of the last two weeks
we've seen not just in the united
kingdom but also in france germany
italy and other comparable countries uh
the spread of the virus being uh greater
than any of us had anticipated two weeks
ago we did know though didn't we
that cases were rising sage were already
recommending a national
lockdown um we knew that deaths may go
up as well
well we also know that at that time the
advice that we were receiving including
from the
uh the chief medical concern the deputy
chief medical officer was that a
regional approach
uh could work as the chief medical
officer last night
said well that's not what patrick valen
said he said that tier three
restrictions weren't going to be enough
to
bring down the spread i i think you're
confusing two things though
the first is that uh sir patrick and
others said that tier three restrictions
on their own would not be enough and
that is why we were in negotiation with
local authorities something we were
discussing two weeks ago
in order to ensure that we had the base
tier three restrictions plus additional
measures
and those additional measures have been
put in place in in liverpool
uh in south yorkshire in nottinghamshire
and elsewhere
but it's also the case as the chief
medical officer pointed out last night
that there's no good time no perfect
time
to act at that stage it was entirely
possible that we might have been able
using a regional approach to balance the
need to combat the virus
with keeping as much of the economy open
as possible and that's always been our
strategy
but just last week i was talking to my
counterpart in the french government
there they were also pursuing a regional
strategy
and indeed augmenting it but again the
spread of the virus there in france
compelled the french president earlier
this week
to acknowledge that a national approach
was required
all of us have been faced with data
which means that the the
original projections about the spread of
the virus actually underestimated it
and again at the time that uh our
scientific and medical advisors
were talking about the future uh uh
spread of the virus there were a number
of people
entirely uh in good faith who questioned
that well actually the situation
has been worse than any of us expected
and that is why action is now required
you're talking there about the situation
being worse than anyone had expected of
course you were in that meeting on
friday
where four of you saw the data that
clearly was alarming
how bad would things have been this
winter well i wouldn't talk about that
meeting uh specifically but more broadly
um the information which uh has
subsequently been shared including at
the prime minister's press conference
last night
shows that if we weren't to take any
further action if we were simply to
leave things as they are
um that we would see uh hospital
capacity during the course of november
uh uh diminish we would see um across
the country
including in areas like the south west
which hitherto have seen less of the
virus
than other parts of the country we would
see hospitals filling up
and very quickly we would have to cancel
elective operations
then we would have to say that uh some
emergency treatments were no longer
viable
then we would have to say that some
people who are currently in hospital
would have to be discharged
the consequences of that if we don't act
is that by the first week in december
the nhs would be full not just full in
normal terms
but incapable of admitting other
patients
when that happens if that happens then
the consequences are as the prime
minister pointed out last night
in moral and in medical terms impossible
to accept
because again what we would see would be
people who
had very serious conditions not capable
of being treated
people with covet who could be treated
in hospital
not capable of being admitted that would
mean
more pain and more death worse than the
first wave
yes that is the the real danger again
the projections that we've seen from a
variety of different sources
it's not simply one group of scientists
but different groups of scientists
all say that without acting uh we would
see
the number of people in hospital exceed
that um
that we saw in the first wave during
this month
around the 20th or so of november and
then as i say nhs capacity
for the occupied and as you will
appreciate uh many people
are understandably concerned and have
argued is this focus on covid
somehow uh a means of neglecting or a
uh it doesn't result in a neglect of
other conditions well one thing is
certain
if our hospitals are full if there's no
more nhs capacity
then that means that those people who
suffer from heart attacks and strokes
and who require cancer treatment
won't get the treatment that they need
so tackling covered
is absolutely central to making sure i
understand
absolutely central to making sure that
we tackle our broader health problems
i'm keen to talk about an exit strategy
yes because we all know once you're in
lockdown
it's very difficult to get out of
lockdown so whatever happens
will this national lockdown end on the
2nd of december or will it be driven by
what the data shows
well we're going to review it on the
second of december but we're always
driven by what the data shows
um uh now on the basis of um so it could
be extended
on the basis of what we've been told um
we believe that the
all of the measures that we're putting
in place will reduce the r
rate below one um as as you and our
viewers know
um that's the point at which you
actually see a decline in the spread of
the virus
rather than its maintenance or increase
so that is the key
data you'll be looking at and if the r
hasn't been brought under one by the
second of december
could the lockdown be extended we're
going to look at all of the data we've
got
um this four week period during which
we're going to
review progress but of course we'll
always be driven by the data
now it's our hope on the basis of the
analysis that we have
that we will have significantly reduced
the reinfection rate um and again one of
the things
that um uh i know is very difficult
because none of these measures are easy
is that people will um understand they
say well this particular restriction
this individual uh restriction is
something that i find particularly
difficult
can we take it away um the the
difficulty is that if we
chop away at all of the restrictions we
may end up in a position
where we don't have a sufficiently
strong team or
bundle or raft of restrictions necessary
in order to get
our below one so to be crystal clear
then what you seem to be saying is
if you're hoping of course the data will
show the infections our
infections are going down that the r is
going down but if the data
on the whole is not looking as you were
hoping then the national lockdown could
be extended
we will always take a decision in the
national interest based on evidence
uh the best information we have is that
yes yes
so it could be it could be extended yes
national
well we want to be in a position where
we can
and i believe that this is likely to be
the case um have uh
an approach where if we bring down the
rate of infection
sufficiently we can reduce measures
nationally and also
reduce measures regionally because the
regional approach is one that
uh wherever possible we want to take
because again we
we recognize that it may be the case in
the future that having reduced r below
one
having reduced national restrictions we
may see a specific upsurge in specific
areas
which will require specific regional
measures okay
um now on thursday uh your colleague uh
robert gemerick
said this to kay burley just want to
show our viewers and yourself
he said this about a national uh
lockdown
he said if it succeeded it is likely
then needed to be repeated regularly you
can't have a stop-start country where
businesses are closing
people are losing their jobs and then
they're having to restart again so even
if this lockdown is
successful you can't rule out further
national lockdowns in the future
well one thing we can definitively say
is that unless we take
action now as we've discussed the nhs is
going to be
um overwhelmed in a way that none of us
could countenance
um so therefore we have to take these
steps but no one um
nobody in government relishes taking
these steps
we believe that by doing this now we
will be in a stronger position
uh later in december to have a more
uh a stronger testing regime um we've
significantly increased testing capacity
and we also believe that we will
further have developed our approach
towards therapeutics and therefore we
will be in a position
better to manage this situation but
again
we'll always be guided by the evidence
on what is right
um and what uh what uh recent weeks
recent months have shown
is that this virus as the prime minister
said um uh
is uh a a terrible force of nature
i think no one would disagree with that
but at the same time do acknowledge that
the very fact that we're
staring down the barrel of another
national lockdown that represents a
failure of the government strategy so
far doesn't it
no i don't think so i think what it
represents is the uh
the the power and the malignancy of the
enemy that we face
um that uh all governments this
government particularly
uh believe in uh liberty do not
want to restrict people's freedoms but
faced with the
ferocity of this virus this government
like other governments
have reluctantly but firmly taken the
steps required in order to
combat it and and one of the reasons for
that is
as we discussed earlier um if we were to
have a situation
where uh we found our nhs overwhelmed
it would also have effects inevitable
effects um on our economy
um and on people's overall confidence
and their ability
to go about their daily lives so this is
a protective step
that we need to take that nobody
relishes um which the prime minister
um reflected on deeply um we all did um
but we feel that uh there is no
alternative
one of the most depressing things about
the situation it feels to me
is that in the first wave 40 000 people
lost their lives a higher death toll in
the highest death toll in europe
and yet it's hard to escape the feeling
that we're not learning the lessons of
that first wave one of the major lessons
was that the quicker you act the shorter
the lockdown
has to be and yet on the 24th of
september sage said that we need a short
two-week national lockdown
you didn't take that advice now we're
looking at a four-week lockdown that
could be extended
why are we making the same mistakes in
the second wave
as we did in the first week well again
i'd refer back to what the chief medical
officer said last night there is no
perfect they said on the 21st of
september that a circuit breaker
should be should happen well there's a
diversity of opinion of course but the
the the view that we had from uh the
chief medical officer the deputy chief
medical officer
um is that um a regional approach was a
way of
balancing restriction of the virus
the economic life of the nation the view
of sage which they chair on this 25th of
september advised a package of
interventions including a circuit
breaker
banning all contact within the home with
members of other households the closure
of all bars restaurants and cafes and i
understand you're going back to the
regional approach
but as we discussed you know your own
chief scientific advisor sir patrick
valen said
the three-tier system on its own won't
work well again as i pointed out earlier
the
the three-tier system uh when you just
have the base
um on its own thought you should have
acted quicker didn't you yeah
that would be the fundamental point here
well the key thing is the
chief medical officer made the point
last night that there is no perfect
time to act and secondarily uh the
the advice that we were receiving at the
time was that it was perfectly
reasonable to take a regional approach
and we weren't
outliers in that regard that was the
position that the french government
the german government and that others
were taking
um we've taken the steps that we have
now uh because we recognized that the
the rate of increase of the virus as i
mentioned earlier and as you
acknowledged
has been greater than was anticipated
and there are lessons that we've learned
from the first
lockdown lessons that we've learned
about how we treat people in hospital
which means that people are less likely
to die
lessons about testing which meant that
we've increased our testing capacity
to uh nearly 500 000 and rising
and also one of the other lessons that
we've learned uh from then
is the vital importance of making sure
that uh we protect the nhs
and also do everything that we can at
the appropriate moment
to support the economy which is also why
the chancellor of the exchequer
announced yesterday the extension of the
furthest one of the major lessons of the
first lockdown
the major mistakes was not protecting
people in care homes some of the most
vulnerable people
and yet once again it feels like you're
making the same mistakes my colleague ed
conway revealed this week that in leeds
for example
covert 19 is now higher in care homes
than at the first
peak of the virus there and the
government guidance still says that
people
who've tested positive can be discharged
from hospitals into care homes no well i
i
i say several things about um the care
home sector the first thing is
that uh we are uh making sure that
the spread of the virus in care hymns um
with the benefit of
the analysis that we've done has often
been linked to people who've been
working in more than one care home
um and what we've done is we've put in
place protocols infection control
protocols
also people been discharged from
hospitals into care the same thing is
happening let me make three points the
first is
that um as we look back the evidence
suggests that the single greatest uh
cause of the spread of the virus in care
homes was from people moving between
them
we have infection control protocols in
order to prevent that secondly
we've provided hundreds of thousands of
pounds to care homes in order to ensure
uh that their staff can effectively
isolate and
staff are being tested as well weekly in
the care home sector
the third thing is that when it comes to
anyone who's being discharged
we're making sure that anyone who is
discharged from
a hospital into a care home is in a
secure and isolated setting
and the care quality commission is
looking at
the increasing capacity of those
specific beds
which ensure that anyone who is
discharged is in a
safe environment so all of this is in
the winter plan for care
that my colleague helen waitley has
published and it is a
detailed plan in order to ensure that we
mitigate and reduce the risk of
infection okay now um you mentioned the
economic support
earlier will that economic support be
extended
to cover the entire period for which
these restrictions
last for well the economic support is
going to extend
for the period until december the 4th
but what we've always said
is that we review the support that we
are giving
uh the chancellor has said that we are
there to put our hands
around individuals and the economies
well again i don't want to anticipate
the decisions that will be taken between
now and december the 4th
as you quite rightly point out with a
virus that's malignant
and with its capacity to move so quickly
um it would be foolish to predict with
absolute certainty what will happen
in four weeks time when over the course
of the last two weeks
its rate its infectiousness um uh its
malignancy
have grown and so therefore of course
we'll review what requires to be done
but we have a clear plan over the course
of the next four weeks to support the
economy
and to protect the nhs why was it
impossible to pay
80 of workers wages in greater
manchester
when two weeks later you did it for the
whole country well one of the things
about that time is that we were seeking
to negotiate with the mayor of
manchester and others in order to ensure
that we could move
from tier two to tier three and the
mayor at the time and
others were arguing that the uh uh that
tier two was where they wanted to stay
even though the economic support
they wanted just one second even though
the economic support they would have got
would have been greater
in tier three and in tier three they
would have received both more economic
support
and also they would have done more to
contribute to restricting
uh the spread of the budget i didn't
agree to 80 of wages
we did agree to a generous economic
package which would have been uh
my question which would have been
welcome had it been introduced earlier
why is it
the the lesson from 80 of workers wages
in greater manchester but okay to pay
the whole country
eight percent awareness now well the two
things the first thing i would say is
that
uh the delay in greater manchester in
moving towards tier three
has led to an increase in infections the
the evidence shows that
and then the third thing is that we were
talking to local leaders about what was
required
in circumstances where the restrictions
were uh
uh less than than they will be now
because the the restrictions that we're
putting in place across the united
kingdom
are stricter uh for understandable
reasons and reasons that we've discussed
than the restrictions that would have
been in place in greater manchester
at that time just finally and there's an
inquiry
into who revealed details of the
lockdown on friday
of course we know who was in the meeting
was the chancellor the prime minister
and the house secretary should the
person who leaked the details keep their
job
well there's a leak inquiry going on and
it's for the prime minister and the
cabinet secretary
to decide what action needs to be taken
but what do you think
i think it's for the prime minister and
the cabinet secretary to decide uh that
investigation i think is very important
uh because it's absolutely vital that
when we have discussions
uh serious discussions uh that it's
possible for
myself and for other ministers and more
critically for our advisors
to feel that they can share information
in confidence i think that's very
important